here's my first letter tells me I got to
have resampling a month later little
over a month later again my well water
is not safe to drink then the third
letter I get says my water is safe to
drink almost 11 months later stating no
colitis is there leading the nation in
coal ash cleanup
this ain't leading no nation in coerce
cleanup telling people to drink
contaminated water that you have told me
twice not to drink that's not being a
leader what you have is a system
guaranteed to pollute a system a
primitive storage we wouldn't allow
anyone else to do and a system that is
primed for catastrophe every day they
are polluting groundwater rivers and
lakes with toxic metals the companies
have a reason not to clean up they can't
afford to and still make coal profitable
if you took all the profit that's made
burning coal it's not enough dollars to
clean up after the mess that coal leaves
behind coal ash is an enormous problem
across this country there are about a
thousand coal ash sites with very heavy
levels of pollution ultimately ending up
in some waterway that people are relying
on for drinking water it's a ticking
time bomb for millions of Americans ok
what's your name buddy
kill her up sit her on down we know that
Duke Energy is never going to emit this
because if they do there's six other
states waiting to pound on them we know
that we just want them to do the right
thing clean the mess up clean up their
own trash on their own property just
like they would expect us to do and
provide us clean safe water we know too
much now to turn around and back up and
we are not going away
[Music]
Oh